adidas question is definitely the right
question to ask you know I have to say
frankly that it's incredibly impressive
that a girl effect topic is one of the
main topics on the Davos agenda this
year especially considering the
incredibly challenging financial crisis
that we're working through so don't have
this on the man agenda on the devil's
agenda and frankly one of the most
popular sessions here amidst this period
of time is it was really important
because here we are on it's the world's
top business and political leaders all
listening and understanding better how
important it is for us to focus on
supporting adolescent girls in
developing countries around the world
all 600 million of them who really
frankly need that support from all of us
they happen to be one of the most
neglected unsupported risk parts of the
global population and our ability to
support them can actually create the
most impact I think in terms of specific
parts of the population around the world
helping them realize their potential
will really help us as a world
population reach our potential thank you